Radiation therapy is one of
the most well used applications
of optimization in health care.
In practice,
radiation machines are
connected to treatment
planning software that
implements and solves
optimization models.
Both linear optimization
models, like we
saw here, and other types
of optimization models.
Some examples of
radiation machines
that use optimization
software are
Pinnacle by Philips, RayStation
by RaySearch Labs and Eclipse
by Varian.
There are many extensions
to the optimization model
we described here.
One is the selection
of beam angles.
The beam angles can be selected
jointly with the intensity
profiles by using an
integer optimization.
This allows the treatment
to be further personalized
to the specific tumor and
person receiving the radiation.
Integer optimization is another
type of optimization model
and will be the
topic of next week.
Another extension is
accounting for uncertainty.
Often the quality
of IMRT treatments
is degraded due to
uncertain organ motion.
For example, in lung
cancer, the target area
is around the lungs.
But since the
patient is breathing
throughout the treatment,
the target area is moving
and the location is
slightly uncertain.
We can manage this
uncertainty using
a method known as
robust optimization.
There is a significant amount
of literature on this method
and its application
to radiation therapy.
Linear optimization
significantly
improves the efficiency
of radiation therapy.
Manually designing
an IMRT treatment
would be inefficient
and impractical.
By using linear
optimization, IMRT
can be designed in an
efficient and systematic way.
As we saw in this
lecture, clinical criteria
can be modeled using constraints
and the treatment planner
can explore trade-offs
by changing the model.
But ultimately, IMRT and
the use of optimization
benefits the patient.
In head and neck
cancers saliva glands
were rarely spared
prior to IMRT,
but by using optimized
IMRT treatments,
saliva glands can now be spared.
In prostate cancer,
IMRT treatments
reduced toxicities and
allow for higher tumor doses
to be delivered safely.
And in lung cancer
optimized IMRT
reduced the risk of radiation
induced pneumonitis.
These are just three examples
of the benefits of IMRT.
Overall, optimized
IMRT allows clinicians
to deliver treatment that
was previously impossible
and to improve the quality
of life for patients.